[Musica]
oggi distruggiamo questa prigione Tanto
siamo riusciti a scappare Non ci serve
più via
[Musica]
cos'era questo rumore
per fortuna sono riuscito a far andare
via l'ho visto andare via da qui
Wow C'è mancato veramente poco
poco
perché Luca perché
no no no ma non stavo
distruggendo arriva più questa qui
Tu hai messo prigioni A me sì lo so che
hai messo in prigione per me ma perché
io
le orecchie qua sopra no io le orecchie
ce l'ho qua no qua sopra
Ok
Ricominciamo Ok da capo
[Applauso]
Tutto nuovo
i peli
I miei peli
scusa per non farlo il lupo mannarese
[Musica]
riproviamo
da capo fantastico
tu io io e te io e te erano così facile
io e te Ok io e te
un pomodoro un pomodoro
però questo è il simbolo del pomodoro
Scusami eh Ho capito ho capito perché
sbadato non ci voleva così tanto e alla
fine è semplice hai detto orecchie la
bocca grande Poi il pomodoro eh L'unica
cosa il pomodoro erano quelle
orecchiette pomodoro bocca grande perché
si mangia tutto insieme giusto
[Musica]
le orecchiette il pomodoro la bocca
grande per mangiare tutto insieme cosa
vuoi che capisca io non ti arrabbiare
però non ti arrabbiare non ti arrabbiare
ah ah ah ah ah ah ho un'idea riproviamo
da capo questa volta semplice semplice
allora
io te pomodoro No non era un pomodoro Ok
basta
da capo
Tu sì
[Musica]
mordere con i denti me perchè mi vuoi
mordere
[Musica]
tu morti che nel frattempo mi escono
fuori le orecchie mi si allunga il viso
e diventa veloce
[Musica]
Aiuto aiuto che paura Che paura ha
distrutto tutto
a lungo Allora se già mi hai fatto il
segno del cuore vuol dire che mi vuoi
bene no e se mi vuoi bene non mi vuoi
fare del male tipo mordermi Ma vabbè se
mi morti mi fa male quindi tu non mi
vuoi fare del male è vero ma tipo non
c'è un altro metodo indolore per
trasformarmi perché mi devi per forza
mordere
allora penso di aver capito sta dicendo
aspettate Lasciatemi pensare Ormai sono
state diventando un traduttore
simultaneo Dunque Adesso riprovo
Lasciami pensare e che c'è una soluzione
però
[Musica]
puoi dare dei bacetti agli spettatori No
io
Bacio Io bacio
aiuto
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Mi sta facendo uscire
tu mi vuoi pensare per trasformarmi ho
capito no no no no nooo
[Musica]
ooooooo
oooooooooo
ho mangiato Vitale Forse perché vuole
trasformarlo il lupo mannaro ma io mi
sono travestita da Cappuccetto Rosso
perché ho una trappola per la lupa
Mannara e poi stavo consultando il mio
libro storie paurose a scuola di misteri
Perché ha tante informazioni sulle
creature tra cui i lupi mannari voi ce
l'avete Scrivetemi nei commenti se voi
ce l'avete già letto ma presto vediamo
lo sapevo questa è un'informazione
importantissima sui lupi mannari e
infatti mi basta prendere una cosa
Perfetto ora inizia la trappola per la
lupa andiamo
sono io Cappuccetto Rosso e sono venuta
qua per dirti che sei brutta e pelosa
e hai denti gialli Sì hai i denti gialli
bruttissimi
quindi Vitale non ti vorrà mai
per capitale ama me soltanto me non te
Capito Capito
[Musica]
[Applauso]
beccati questa
[Musica]
prova a prendermi
presto
[Musica]
Dai vieni verso qua sta avvicinando la
mia trappola sta funzionando
Vieni pure a prendermi
Ah ah ah
ah ah
intrappola e in trappola La mia trappola
ha funzionato ora che la lupa in
trappola posso andare a liberare Vitale
Ciao Ciao Luca ciao
Sono arrivata a liberarsi
che cosa vuoi non mi vedi che ormai sono
un lupo mannaro
Buongiorno la trasformazione è già
iniziata
aspetta un po' Ascoltami
ed è stata tutta colpa della lupo
Mannara e che la lupo mannaro che ti ha
trasformato Cappuccetto Rosso è caduto
nella tana del lupo ma che stai facendo
mi sono travestita da Cappuccetto Rosso
per spendere una trappola alla lupo e ci
sono anche riuscita Oh intrappolato la
Luma là fuori
hai intrappolato la lupo là fuori Perché
che cosa vuoi fare Mi è venuta un'idea
visto che hai menzionato la lupa Adesso
vedrai qui con me Ci metterò in cella
Ehi come ti permetti Lasciami stare ti
ho detto tu stai invitare non sei un
lupo Mannarino Scusami io non sono
Cappuccetto Rosso solo l'Inter cerca di
ricordarsi adesso ti ricordo io la cosa
ti metterò in cella e quando tornerà La
Lupa si Mangeremo insieme sarà un
bellissimo banchetto ah ah non credo
proprio perché tu tornerai normale
adesso capito Torna subito normale non
sei un lupo Sì sì certo certo funziona
così
via dicendo
Uffa ma Vitale non sei un lupo se Vitale
Ricordati dei biscotti delle torte della
pasta al sugo e dei ravioli e Insomma
tutte le cose che ti piacciono da
mangiare alla pizza no
la trasformazione proprio completata
devi dare non torna in sequenza dal cibo
allora è veramente completata la
trasformazione non mi resta che passare
al mio piano segreto Ehi quale piano
segreto non ti permettere a mettere i
bastoni tra le ruote tra me e la lupa
Hai capito E perché sentiamo Che cosa
succede se mi metto i bastoni fra le 30
minuti succede che ti mangeremo ancor
prima e ti sgrano tutta
Ma quale biscotti prepareremo un bel
banchetto e ti mangeremo e poi
scapperemo insieme Sì
però e andremo a vivere nella foresta
Sì ululeremo alla luna
[Musica]
Sì ha conquistato il mio cuore vedi mi
ha trasformato in un lupo proprio come
lei basta
la cosa anzi
mi ha detto che era l'uva era
intrappolata là fuori devo andare a
liberarla ha bisogno di me adesso
[Risate]
è arrivato il momento di agire sul mio
piano ho preso queste cose di nascosto
con questi trucchi io creerò il rossetto
d'argento e sapete che l'argento e il
nemico numero uno dei lupi mannari e
Dopo vedrai che cosa succederà ma prima
devo mettere il rossetto
Luca
dove sei Sono io il tuo tesoro lupa
Dove sei andata sento il tuo odore qui
Luca vieni esci fuori sono venuto a
salvarti
Dai che ci aspetta un bel banchetto
Ehi ma era proprio qui sento il suo
odore
sarà qui intorno o forse è già entrato
in casa ma Ehi non può mica iniziare a
mangiare senza di me devo raggiungerla
Devo dirti una cosa Che cosa devo dirti
una cosa all'orecchio
e sentiamo allora è un segreto quindi
devi avvicinarti di più
Ok mi avvicino di più
[Musica]
ma non sento niente
cos'è Cosa hai fatto
il rossetto d'argento e l'argento è
l'arma numero uno contro i lupi mannari
quindi
lo
Remo per evitare tornerai il mio
fidanzato che cosa hai fatto Ma come non
puoi tornare normale voglio solo un lupo
non sono più vitale questa cosa brucia
che cosa mi hai fatto
sta funzionando cosa sta succedendo dai
dai dai
sbrigati sbrigati argento Sbrigati a
funzionare
tornate normale ma mi riconosce adesso
non sono Cappuccetto Rosso sono Anita mi
ha riconosciuto Certo che ti riconosco
la Cappuccetto Rosso però sì ti
riconosco bene allora Liberami subito
prima che torni la lupa Ma che ci fai
inclusa là dentro Certo che devi dirmelo
Dai vieni chiusa tu
davvero
[Musica]
papà
ti è rimasta male che tu hai baciato me
e soprattutto che sei tornato normale
non sei più lupo
e Lupa Mi dispiace però eh La mia
fidanzata tu mi hai trasformato eh eh eh
Dai poverino vieni Siediti tipo mi
dispiace magari troverai
un lupo vero lupo mannaro adatto a te
sai troverai quello giusto per te Vedrai
[Applauso]
Poverina adesso mi fa pena adesso che
non ha quella quell'istinto assassino mi
fa un po' pena no Dai magari ti aiutiamo
noi a trovare un fidanzato
Ah ah ah ah
no Poverina cosa facciamo Dai Luca vai
io un'idea eh Che ne pensi se hai
mangiato ogni tanto ti inviteremo a casa
Eh che cosa ne pensi così potrei venire
a trovarci Passeremo un po' di tempo
insieme e così io avrei due nuovi amici
no
no non possiamo invitare un vero lupo
mannaro così grosso a casa nostra ma
adesso la vedi tutta tranquilla è dolce
è triste ma magari le tornerà questo
istinto assassino E dai poverina mi fa
pena Dai vieni qua ti do l'ultimo
abbraccio Hehehe
bravo
Mi sei stritolando
Piano piano Allora continuiamo le
distanze
brava sì sì Avrei due nuovi amici non un
fidanzato due nuovi amici
No no noi due Noi due dai dai dai dai
dai potrei venire a trovarci Quando
vorrai
facciamo passare un po' di mesi tra
l'altro una visita dell'altra uh ah
vabbè vabbè i giorni facciamo passare un
po' di giorni
sì dai va bene a una volta ci potrai
tornare a trovare una una volta ok solo
una volta Ehi ma voi cliccate mi piace
se volete che la lupa torni a trovarci
un'altra volta cliccate Mi piace questa
stupida e quindi dai ci vediamo un'altra
volta Ciao ci vediamo Ciao ciao ciao
[Musica]
ciao ciao ciao
e ciao ciao
[Musica]
Vai via Insomma non se ne voleva più
andare beh avevo scampato anche questa
che è dormita
Buongiorno Anita
[Musica]